Transcription: Sandra Lanos
Relecteur: eric vautier
La meilleure façon de préserver le vivant,
c’est de ne rien faire.
Plutôt facile,
en tout cas, bien moins coûteux
que de tenter de recréer
ce que nous aurons détruit.
Je viens vous parler de libre évolution,
de ces espaces
où le vivant et les processus naturels
s’expriment pleinement.
Et plus particulièrement,
de ces réservoirs de biodiversité
que sont les forêts,
lorsque l’on décide de les protéger.
Une forêt n’est pas un champ d’arbres.
Une forêt ne saurait se résumer
à une plantation réalisée par l’homme.
Une forêt, c’est un magnifique écosystème
complexe, riche,
où de nombreuses espèces
animales, végétales,
fongiques, microbiennes
vivent en interdépendance.
Que ce soit pour le stockage du carbone,
la filtration de l’eau
ou la stabilisation des sols,
la forêt est véritablement
dotée de super-pouvoirs.
Vous l’aurez compris,
je ne viens pas vous parler
de planter des arbres.
Je viens vous parler de protéger
ce qui est encore autour de nous.
Ce que nous serons bien incapables
de recréer une fois disparu.
Protéger nos forêts
pour elles-mêmes.
Pour le vivant qu’elles abritent
et plus égoïstement,
pour les services écologiques
qu’elles nous rendent.
Vous le savez,
ces écosystèmes sont incroyablement
riches en biodiversité.
L’ONU estime que les deux tiers
des espèces terrestres
vivent dans les forêts
ou dépendent d’elles pour leur survie.
Protéger les forêts
parce que le carbone qu’elles stockent
dans leur sol ou dans leurs arbres
est un formidable atout
contre le changement climatique.
Protéger les forêts
parce qu’elles détiennent probablement
les clés de notre propre résilience.
Ce que nous faisons
au travers de la libre évolution,
c’est de permettre aux arbres
qui composent ces écosystèmes
d’accomplir leur cycle de vie complet.
De la germination d’une graine
jusqu’à la senescence.
Nous permettons à plus d’un quart
de la biodiversité forestière -
des animaux, des oiseaux,
des champignons, des bactéries
qui dépendent du bois mort - d’exister.
Ce sont ces mêmes espèces qui,
en décomposant le bois mort,
participent au cycle du carbone
et enrichissent les sols.
Elles nous sont vitales.
Y compris dans nos activités économiques
aujourd’hui issues des forêts.
Ce que nous faisons
avec la libre évolution,
c’est donner une capacité de résilience
maximale à nos forêts.
En 2019, je cofonde
l’association « État sauvage »,
convaincue qu’une énergie
en appelle d’autres.
Une idée me porte,
celle que face à l’urgence écologique,
chacun peut agir à son niveau.
Et que nous pouvons
toutes et tous être les moteurs
de ce changement
que nous appelons de nos vœux.
Mais ce n'est pas la première
fois que je m'engage.
J’ai grandi à la campagne, en France.
Petite, je passais presque le plus clair
de mon temps dans le jardin ou la forêt.
Étonnant.
À l’âge de dix ans,
je crée mon premier club.
Et...
je décide de sensibiliser autour de moi
à ce que l’on appelle
« la condition animale ».
Pour constituer ma première cagnotte,
je me mets à faire du porte à porte
dans mon village.
Et je décide de revendre à mes voisins
les autocollants que
le Parc naturel régional m’avait offerts.
Aujourd'hui, je fais toujours appel
à la générosité de mes voisins.
Mais heureusement, ils sont plus nombreux
grâce aux réseaux sociaux.
État sauvage a pour mission
de préserver la biodiversité,
mais aussi d’encourager les liens positifs
que l’humanité entretient avec la nature.
Notre collectif agit
en France métropolitaine
et fonde son action sur deux axes :
sensibiliser aux grands
enjeux environnementaux
et préserver les écosystèmes
en créant des réserves pour le vivant.
Concrètement, nous achetons
des forêts pour les préserver.
Nous faisons le choix de gestion
de ne plus intervenir dans ces forêts,
de les laisser en libre évolution.
Face aux bouleversements
qui nous attendent,
nous acceptons
de faire confiance au vivant.
Nous reconnaissons
et acceptons notre interdépendance
avec ce que l’on nomme « le sauvage ».
Nous avons déjà acquis
deux forêts en France.
Une dans le Cantal,
l’autre dans les Vosges.
Ce sont dix hectares
qui sont rendus à la nature.
Et nous travaillons actuellement
sur l’acquisition d’une troisième forêt.
Alors c’est vrai,
dix hectares, c’est minuscule
au regard des 17 millions d’hectares
de forêts de France métropolitaine.
De la même manière que
nous ne sommes qu’une dizaine de bénévoles
sur les 67 millions
de Françaises et de Français.
Mais justement,
n’est-ce pas là le plus important ?
Si, avec de faibles moyens,
une poignée d’entre nous
a déjà réussi à protéger ces surfaces,
imaginez le pouvoir
que nous avons ensemble.
C’est ce message que je souhaite
partager avec vous ce soir.
Nous avons le pouvoir de mettre en œuvre
cette solution pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique
et la disparition accélérée du vivant.
C’est le pouvoir de simples citoyennes
et citoyens qui ont décidé d’agir,
qui ont décidé
de changer les règles du jeu
et de ne plus attendre
que les décideurs prennent
les bonnes décisions.
Acceptons de lâcher prise.
Acceptons que
la nature n’ait pas besoin de nous,
mais que nous sommes dépendants d’elle.
Acceptons que la nature,
si nous lui en laissons la possibilité,
est capable de se régénérer.
Je vous invite, à votre échelle,
à laisser une véritable place au vivant
dans toute sa complexité.
Que ce soit dans vos jardins,
dans vos squares,
dans vos lacs ou vos forêts,
laissez une partie de ces espaces naturels
en libre évolution.
(Applaudissements)